hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty science
chemistry phd skin care nerd and big fan of
chemicals and today i'm going to finally do a
big overview of some of the ordinary's products
this brand has a lot of products and i wanted to
try as many as i could and i only have one face
so this has taken quite a while i could only
get through a few categories though and this
isn't even all the products i've tried so i'm only
going to cover a few of them and if there's enough
interest then i'll talk about the other categories
next time so in this video i'm going to be going
through the direct acids vitamins a b and c the
hydrators and oils and the cleansers i've picked
out the best and worst products in my opinion from
these categories and i'll talk about them today
remember that my skin is not your skin you might
really love a product that i really don't like and
that's fine you shouldn't stop using it just
because i said i didn't like it this goes for
any brand or product but i think this applies even
more when it comes to the ordinary because of how
they approach their product development which i'll
go into in a bit if you like this sort of video
click the like and the subscribe and click the
nerdification bell so you don't miss any videos
ever since they launched the ordinary have really
transformed the skin care market and i think
they're one of the big reasons that everyone is so
obsessed with the science behind skin care now i
think it's the magical combination of being really
affordable as well as having the ingredient names
front and center on their products so now we can
suddenly afford to try all of these fancy sounding
technical ingredients and so we want to know what
they do the way that the ordinary have managed to
stay so budget friendly is by really simplifying
the formulations of their products this can work
really well for some ingredients but for other
ingredients it really reduces their stability
and effectiveness and that's why i think the
ordinary's products can be so hit and miss and the
overall formulation the process that the ordinary
has cut out to cut down on costs can be really
important so this is stuff like making a formula
testing it on a range of skin types tweaking it
based on that feedback and then testing it
again and doing that repeatedly to optimize
the formula can be really important for making it
work for a range of skin types when dr davin lim
and i talked to deciem's chief scientific officer
i'll link that interview in the description it
doesn't sound like they went through any sort of
this optimization process before they launched
their products which is something that every
brand is meant to do at the very least for
safety reasons so this is why everything is so
cheap but it does also explain the massive range
of experiences that you can see people having with
particular products so you'll see a whole bunch of
one star reviews where a product gave them massive
cystic acne chemical burns massive irritation
and then five star reviews as well where the
product was completely life-changing the packaging
is also really low cost so it's just a bunch of
dropper bottles and flip top lid tubes which means
that they can save a lot of money because they
don't have to buy fancier packaging plus they can
reuse the packaging for a whole bunch of different
products so they get that bulk buy discount
so some products will go off a lot faster than
they might in different packaging because some
ingredients do really need that extra protection
from something like an airless pump or a foil tube
so with a more expensive brand not always but
it is a general trend for brands who really put
a lot of thought into their formulations and their
price reflects that you can generally pick up any
product and there's a pretty good chance that
it'll work for your skin without any unnecessary
irritation but with the ordinary you have to put
in a lot more effort to work out what will and
won't work for you and a lot of people who have
more tolerant and forgiving skin will really enjoy
that journey and experimentation but if you just
want to pick low-fuss products with minimal effort
and if you want to lower the risk of a bad
reaction then the ordinary probably isn't for you
this approach also means that if an
ordinary product didn't work for you
then you shouldn't write off that ingredient a
better formula might still work for your skin
so just be careful with that it is sort of a
cheap way to try out lots of different active
ingredients but at the same time you aren't
really giving that ingredient a fair chance
one final thing i wanted to talk about is that
the low price of the ordinary's products means
that it's really accessible but it also means that
it's really tempting to just buy a whole bunch of
products and slap them all on your skin it's like
being a kid in a candy store this is a really
efficient shortcut to burning the crap out of
your skin and it can take ages months to recover
the fact that so many products are single
ingredient also tends to encourage people to do
too much to their skin when products are assessed
for irritation before they're released when
ingredients have percentages that are recommended
for use in products this is assuming that you'll
only be using one or two products not that you'll
be piling five products on top of each other
the ordinary's regimen guide is actually pretty
sensible they don't really recommend more than
two or three active ingredients in a routine
but i see a lot of people do it anyway i think
the ordinary could make it clearer that you
shouldn't use that many products at once because
it's really obvious that people are ignoring
their guidelines but i guess people are going
to do what they're going to do and it's hard to
expect a company to check what's in your cart
and then put up an alert saying "are you sure you
want to buy all of this?" so if you're getting
into the ordinary try not to get too excited
introduce one new product every two weeks or
so to your skin so you don't overwhelm it
and irritate it and that way you can also
really assess if that specific product is really
necessary for you so let's go on to the products
simple formulas tend to work quite well for
acid exfoliants so these are some of the
ordinary's most popular products lactic acid
is my favorite alpha hydroxy acid exfoliant
as a reminder alpha hydroxy acids or ahas are
chemical exfoliants that help dead skin cells
unstick and so this tends to help with things like
clogged pores texture and pigmentation but they
do also make your skin more sensitive to burning
with uv so make sure you're already using a good
sunscreen in your routine before you start using
these lactic acid is generally less irritating
than glycolic acid although it does depend on the
formulation this one is really gentle and it can
be hard to find lactic acid products on the market
especially affordable ones when this was launched
i'm pretty sure there weren't any affordable ones
on the market i think the five percent is a really
good starter exfoliant or if your skin is really
sensitive and easily irritated by acids if you
like what the five percent is doing for your skin
and you want to go stronger then switch to the 10%
and i really like that both of these are in the
range because there's an obvious progression
the glycolic acid toning solution has been one of
my favorite ordinary products ever since i started
using it it's just a really simple glycolic
acid exfoliant a really simple no-frills sort
of product it also works well as an acid deodorant
if you want to go down that route and the bottle
is so big and is so inexpensive that you can
put it on all the ingrowns in your body as well
the main issue that i have with it is that it
kind of does encourage overuse with the name the
toning solution it sounds like a product that most
people can use every day without much irritation
it's also only seven percent but on my skin it
feels stronger than seven percent it's comparable
to other 10% or 15% acid exfoliants so don't treat
this like a toner treat it as a chemical exfoliant
if your skin is easily irritated or if you're
already using irritating products in your routine
then treat it really carefully but if your skin
likes chemical exfoliation if you use it really
sensibly if you step it up really slowly then it
is a really great product if you're wondering how
to sensibly step up your exfoliation i have a
free guide on setting up an exfoliation routine
i'll link that down below i also don't think
there's any need for a cotton pad for exfoliants
i apply them all with my fingers the cotton
pad is also kind of rough and so it adds some
physical exfoliation to your routine as well and
a lot of the time you just don't really need that
so the famous 30% aha peel this is the red one
you've probably seen around everywhere i'm putting
this in the worst category because i know that it
works for a lot of people but a lot of people also
abuse it it's sort of like st ives apricot scrub
there's nothing inherently wrong with the product
when it's used safely but with all the hype around
it a lot of people are not using it safely this
is a really high concentration wash off chemical
exfoliant it's the sort of thing that can give you
a chemical burn if you're not careful and i really
do think people need to be experienced acid users
before they start using this so it's for someone
who's been using chemical exfoliants for at least
a few years maybe they've had some professional
peels as well so they know how it should feel
and maybe they've over exfoliated a few times
so they know what can go wrong i've seen people
dermarolling over this people using it every day
people leaving it on for way too long the ordinary
do have lots of warnings about this so they do say
it's for experienced users only they say that you
shouldn't use it more than twice a week although i
still think that is too much even though a lot of
people are using it sensibly the easy availability
means that a lot of people also aren't and so i
think it's the sort of thing where it would
be better to have more regulations around it
so for example if it was an over-the-counter drug
where you had to at least talk to a pharmacist
before you could buy it in australia it's actually
illegal to sell this product it's illegal to have
products that are over 20% glycolic acid
at a low pH outside of salon use i used to
think that this policy was really unnecessary and
overprotective but now that i've seen how people
use this product and i've talk to estheticians
and dermatologists who have been telling me that
people are coming in with really bad chemical
burns and irritated skin and just destroyed
barriers from using this product i'm starting to
see that yeah this policy does make a lot of sense
retinoids are the gold standard ingredients of
skin care they're really good for lots of things
like acne fine lines hyperpigmentation there are a
bunch of prescription ones that are more powerful
and usually more irritating and there's a bunch of
ones that are allowed in cosmetic products these
are generally a bit weaker retinol is the most
common vitamin a you'll find in cosmetic products
and it is really unstable it needs those
extra bells and whistles to make it from
the manufacturer to your house and then once
you've opened the bottle it will start degrading
and so it needs to be slowed down there plus it
also needs to be delivered deeper into your skin
for it to actually work and with the ordinary
you kind of have the worst of everything here
it does have a brown bottle which protects it
from light but the dropper is open to the air the
simple formula means that there isn't much helping
it stay stable once you've opened it and the lack
of testing and optimization means that there's not
much going on with the formulation to tweak it to
make it more stable or to make it go deeper into
your skin there's actually a recent study that
looked at how much retinoids degraded in products
they tested a bunch of different products and it
was really variable and this is something that a
lot of larger companies really put a lot of effort
and focus and research into neutrogena's formula
is optimized and stabilized so much that they can
keep it in a jar and it has a two-year shelf life
with the ordinary's one with zero optimization
unsurprisingly it is not so good in the study
which tried to replicate real-world conditions
there was only 30% left after six months the
degradation also follows first order kinetics
which means that the degradation happens fastest
at the start pk also said in our interview that he
recommends keeping it in the fridge and throwing
it out after three months and i just don't think
that's worth it if you want a retinol product
get a product from a brand that has conducted
stability testing and is happy to stand by that
basically look at the packaging see if it mentions
stability if it doesn't then ask the company
if they can guarantee the stability if you're
in a country like australia where tretinoin is
relatively easy to get then i would recommend that
because drugs have guaranteed stability and shelf
life on the flip side tretinoin is more irritating
so in that study i mentioned they also looked
at the ordinary's granactive retinoid and they
found that it was really stable with only about
15% degrading after six months this isn't really
surprising because granactive retinoid's active
ingredient which is hydroxypinacolone retinoate
it was designed specifically to be stable
studies have also found that it's meant to be
more effective with less irritation although the
studies were all conducted by the manufacturer so
there's possible bias there anecdotally most
people say that this just isn't irritating at
all there are a few different versions that
the ordinary have they have the emulsion and
they have a bunch in squalane i'd recommend
the emulsion because emulsions in general
deliver these sorts of ingredients better
into your skin but as far as i know the
ordinary haven't really done efficacy studies
on their formulas so it is a bit of a best guess
i've talked about the powders before and how i
really don't like them i think they're just lazy
products and they're really unnecessary and if
you look at the prices they are kind of a rip-off
first off with vitamin c vitamin c is a
really good antioxidant that's good at
protecting your skin against free radical damage
from things like uv it's also been recorded to
fade pigment and increased collagen and that's
why it's regulated in japan as a quasi drug
the issue is that the effectiveness of vitamin
c really depends on formulation and the best
tested version which is l-ascorbic acid which
is also probably the most common one it is
massively unstable in water-based products with
ascorbic acid it's already a really irritating
ingredient and a lot of people who are trying
properly formulated l-ascorbic acid serums
are already getting really irritated
so this is like an extension of that
if you already like ascorbic acid and your skin is
made of steel then this product might work for you
or if you want a product that you can use on your
body without worrying too much about the price so
you can just mix this into some body lotion your
body skin is generally less easily irritated
and you have a lot more leeway because you're
applying a lot more product that could work
but if you just buy a pure ascorbic acid from a
supplement store it ends up being a lot cheaper
it works out to be 80 cents for the amount that's
sold in this product which is about six dollars
so i feel like there really isn't much point to
this product unless you really like the jar or
you're not sure you'll keep on using it or if
you're just trying to use up your free shipping
the vitamin c suspensions are safer products
that have the same benefits in terms of stability
it's a lot easier to dispense a safe
amount of a 30% product than it is of
a hundred percent product and they also
don't have water so they're very stable
but the instructions are really not that great and
i think that's why we're seeing a lot of people
also getting chemical burns with this i actually
really like this type of product but you have to
mix it with something else before you apply it
on your skin something water-based so that the
ascorbic acid can dissolve and spread out properly
but the instructions do just say to apply straight
to your face and i think that's where it really
goes wrong and why i'm hesitant to put it in the
best category so i'm going to invent a third
category which i'm going to call the ehhhh
category which is where i put products
that will work really well for some people
honestly there isn't really a standout vitamin
c product in the ordinary's range that i feel
comfortable recommending in general so i like the
suspensions but the way you use them has to be
just ignoring the instructions ascorbic acid
derivatives can be a good option in terms of
stability and less irritation but i really do
think you need to have studies to show that
they get delivered into skin and the ordinary
just doesn't have that for their formulations
but if i did have to pick a best vitamin c
product from the ordinary i would pick the
ascorbyl tetraisopalmitate it's more stable than
ascorbic acid and i liked it when i used it but
it didn't have the same wow effect that i get
from a good vitamin c product so this would be
my pick if you specifically want something from
the ordinary or if you can't handle ascorbic
acid but if you really want a proper vitamin
c product i would go with a different brand
niacinamide or vitamin b3 is a really popular
ingredient because it's really versatile it
works for a whole bunch of people it's not very
irritating and it does a bit of everything so
it can help with acne pigmentation texture it
actually helps with irritation and restores your
barrier and it's a really great addition
to sunscreen but it's an ingredient where
i think the formulation can make a really big
difference my skin didn't really have massive
benefits from the 10% ordinary one but it loved
the paula's choice one so with something like
this it's really throwing the dice and i really
don't think you need to go higher than 10 or 15%
there aren't any studies showing benefits
with higher percentages and there are a lot
of dermatologists and estheticians who are
saying that people are reacting to higher
percentages and niacinamide is in so many products
these days and it's not unstable like vitamin c
so i just really don't see the need for this
product i mean i can see why they have this
product because the first version did so well
it would be silly not to capitalize on that
but in terms of people's skincare routines
i just don't see the need for this
so the niacinamide 10% i'm
putting in the ehhhh category
it is their best-selling product so
clearly it works for a lot of people
but on some people it just caused
them to have really nasty cysts
and on some people like me it was just really not
that impressive i actually liked it when i tried
it but then i tried the paula's choice and that
really showed me what niacinamide could do i think
the breakouts that this caused in some people
made them think that niacinamide wasn't for them
but from what i can tell it probably wasn't the
niacinamide itself it's something else in the
formulation so i do think this formulation is
probably giving niacinamide a bad name which is
a pity because niacinamide is in so many products
if you're trying to avoid it you have to avoid so
much so if you do react to this product or you're
just not impressed by it don't necessarily give
up on niacinamide although i do understand if
you're just not willing to take that risk again
the ordinary have a lot of plant oils and plant
oils tend to be expensive and they go off really
quickly so it's awesome that they have these now
no one needs to use oils oils are emollients that
means they sink into your skin a little bit and
smooth it out if you use a lot of oils they can
also act as an occlusive which seals in water
but if you use a balanced moisturizer that has
all three types of moisturizer so occlusives and
emollients as well as humectants which grab onto
water and keep your skin hydrated you're going
to get better results than with something like
an oil which is very one note but if your skin
is dry then extra oil can help and if you like
the feel of an oil that's great as well also you
don't necessarily need to avoid oils if you have
oily skin i have oily skin and i really like
oils in winter when my skin goes a bit flaky
and also as a final layer to put on top of
everything else i really do wish they had the
production dates of their oils on the packaging so
you had a better idea of when it was going to go
off but for the price it's really hard to complain
my recommendations are the rosehip and marula oils
but different people like different oils and
some oils break some people out and not others
so my skin works really well with rosehip but
other people say it really clogs their pores
squalane is fantastic if you want an oil well
not really an oil but an oil-like product
that doesn't go off easily it's the hydrogenated
version of squalene which goes off really easily
because it has a double bond double bonds are
why plant oils tend to go off easily as well
they're really reactive so this has a much
longer shelf life and so if you're like me
and you only use tiny amounts of oil then this
is really good mineral oil works well for this
as well but i personally feel that mineral
oil doesn't really sink into my skin as well
again it's not a complete moisturizer it's mostly
just an emollient so if you feel like your skin
is still drying out or if it's not softening
your skin enough then go for a proper balanced
complete moisturizer the downside of squalane is
that it doesn't have those extra antioxidants that
you find in plant oils which is why a lot of us
love plant oils but that's the trade-off you get
i was really pleasantly surprised by the squalane
cleanser because it's one of their few properly
formulated products and it's actually formulated
really well it's basically a cleansing balm in
a tube so this is pretty good at melting off
sunscreen and makeup not as good as some of the
oilier cleansing balms i've used but it is still
really good it spreads nicely on your skin and it
washes off reasonably well if you're not familiar
with this sort of product you massage it on your
dry skin then you wash it off i personally step
into the shower and wash it off with warm water i
use this as my first cleanse and i follow up with
a foaming cleanser i don't think i could use this
on its own effectively if i had a lot of makeup
on but i think some people use it with a washcloth
and that tends to work better i think it would
be good if the ordinary had a normal cleanser in
their lineup as well because i think this is just
a bit confusing for people but i do really like it
i got this when i was in the uk and i really don't
like it it's not approved in australia although
they said that they are working on getting
some of their newer sunscreens in australia
i'm hoping they'll be better because this has
a horrific white cast and it's just really
thick and poor clogging i think sunscreen is
one of the products that doesn't really work
well with the ordinary's business model with
sunscreens the formulation is so important that
you need to have those rounds of optimization
and the ordinary just doesn't really do that
the natural moisturizing factors is another ehhhh
product for me this is a really good moisturizer
if you have oily skin and you have a lot of other
moisturizing ingredients in your routine so from
things like serums it's really lightweight
it doesn't add much grease to your skin
but a lot of the serums from the ordinary don't
have those extra moisturizing ingredients in
them because of the simple formulations and
this is just not a very complete moisturizer
i think that's because the ordinary do
sell other moisturizing ingredients on
their own so all the plant oils as well as the
hyaluronic acid serum and they expect you to
use them all together so that makes sense but
i think the range is really missing a proper
well-rounded moisturizer that will work for most
people as a really good moisturizer if you have
dry skin this is probably not going to work for
you and if you only use the ordinary products for
the rest of your routine it probably won't work
for you either but for my oily skin and for my
completely disloyal routine where i use tons of
different brands this works really well but there
are so many other really effective moisturizers
on the market that i think you can just skip this
the azelaic acid suspension is
another ehhhh product for me
it's not an ingredient that i tend to use a lot in
my routine there are some studies on it for things
like acne and rosacea and hyperpigmentation but
from talking to a lot of veteran dermatologists
they call it an active ingredient in search of
a disease basically some companies really wanted
to make azelaic acid happen and so they just
tested it against a whole bunch of conditions
the studies use really high concentrations
so like 20% twice a day and so it's just not
a very powerful ingredient and that also means
there's a lot of limits in your routine because
it has to work well with the rest of your stuff
because you have to keep using it all the time
plus the formulations are just really
difficult because you have 10 to 20%
of a powder in there but it is pretty
non-irritating and it's safe in pregnancy and
a lot of people have a lot of success with it this
particular version is pretty hit-and-miss it's got
a pretty sticky formulation that tends to ball up
if you use too much and if you don't use enough
then you don't really get those azelaic acid
benefits i prefer the paula's choice formula but
this one is more budget-friendly there's also the
proper drug versions of azelaic acid which i think
are always the best option if you can get them
and if they work well for you there's just extra
levels of guarantees of effectiveness and quality
when it comes to a pharmaceutical product so this
does have some really great reviews but i do think
there are better azelaic acid products out there
so those are my opinions on these
products from the ordinary do you agree
do you like the ones i like or do you hate them
or do you really like the ones that i don't like
is there maybe a really underrated product that
i missed let me know in the comments also let me
know if you want me to go through the rest of
the ordinary's products or if you want to see
a different brand like maybe the inkey list
if you like this video and you want to see
more like it click the like and the subscribe you
can also follow me on instagram and check out my
blog i've also started trying to make tiktok
videos so you can check me out there as well
and tag me in anything that you want me to
bust in terms of myths it seems like there is
a lot of misinformation on tiktok thank you for
watching and see you next time to nerd out more